okay here - who is working on polio
virus and did
fantastic work at that time was a very
very young young scientist so you
already his reputation preceded him a
long time before I met him actually but
as you know he spent most of his career
at MIT brief period at the Salk and has
been president of two universities
Rockefeller and then subsequently a
little bit later Caltech he's of course
very famous for getting the Nobel Prize
in 75 for essentially the reversed order
of the then central dogma through the
discovery of reverse transcriptase he's
just done a lot of really wonderful
things and on top of all of that he's a
generous person he's pretty
unpretentious for a scientist he's
produced an unbelievable number you know
I'm not remembering how many people like
me yeah he's produced an unbelievable
number of trainees which is a very good
assay for a for a person actually and
there are others who haven't produced as
many for different reasons and so I mean
the world is populated with David's a
very successful protegees I would say
that he's very many other
characteristics he's very direct and I
would say probably accurately he doesn't
suffer fools readily and he had to deal
with quite a few of those at least at
one of the places he worked at so just
to be a little bit under political II
incorrect but anyway David I got to know
very well over me over a long time and
we actually had a chance to work do
similar work together over the last five
or so years because we were we were both
working with the Gates Foundation on on
humanized mice for various projects so
anyway it's um it's a great pleasure to
see you again and have here your
wonderful I'm sure talk
welcome David Baltar
it's nice of you all to stay it's been a
long day but a very exciting one and
appropriately so to celebrate an
institution's 200th year of existence
the reason that Richard heard about me
so many years ago is that I guess I've
been doing science for about quarter of
that time which is just daunting to
think back on I hadn't wouldn't have
really thought about it if Harold hadn't
estimated his 20% it's it's terrific to
have a symposium to celebrate an
institution's long period of time it
makes you think back it's a little hard
to imagine what science was like 200
years ago but it is possible to think
back to what science was like 50 years
ago and it just bears no relation to
what we can do today and it has been
pleasure and a tremendous satisfaction
to see this remarkable development of
capability so that we could take apart
the skin the way we were just hearing it
well micro rna's are a
we need to figure out how to get to the
next slide maybe this thing not this
thing there's something I don't know no
it's a test oh he didn't turn away from
so let me talk a little bit about micro
rna's and Phil sharp gave a wonderful
introduction which makes this slide in
particular unnecessary I will say that
I'm not totally happy with the estimates
of either the number of micro rna's
which is generally quoted as a thousand
which is probably an overestimate nor
would the number of genes that are
controlled by micro rna's which I'm not
sure are as many as we think but there
is no question that they are extremely
important and the key things about micro
rna's are one that they're transcribed
by Paul too and therefore their own
regulation is in trim in principle as
complicated as the regulation of the
transcription of any gene and thus they
become part of the network of gene
control and that once they're packed
into the RISC complex they're very
stable and there are clearly mechanisms
for destabilizing them there probably
are interesting stories to be told about
half-lives but in general they're really
very stable when they get out into the
RISC complex and start looking for
messenger RNAs to control
so micro rna's then are a piece of the
regulatory puzzle and it is sort of
amazing that we thought so much about
regulation without knowing of their
existence for so many years in a sense
what they've done in the last five years
or so is to be upgraded from what looked
like fine tuning agents and they are
fine tuning engines but that was sort of
a way of considering them to be
peripheral to the central activities of
regulation to be upgraded into a
partnership with transcription factors
and signal transduction proteins and
others that regulate the networks of
regulation the networks of control that
combined together to be the regulation
of complex organisms so I want to talk
today only about how they integrate into
the regulation of hematopoietic cells
and particularly the cells of the innate
immune system cells that get lots of
attention here in particular that
mediate inflammatory responses so why do
we have micro rna's at all we don't
actually of course know the answer to
that question terribly well because it's
a little hard to piece together their
evolution but as I've been thinking
about this particularly in the last
couple of weeks I was struck by the fact
that our models for regulation of
transcription our models of actually
based largely on thinking about maniatis
--is enhances so a lot of regulatory
proteins all working together to
influence the bound RNA polymerase at
the transcriptional start site and so
it's a cooperative venture it's not one
protein interacting with one DNA
sequence it's many proteins acting with
many interacting with many
a sequences and then interacting with
many proteins on top of that and so it's
quite possible that as systems evolved
in the over the time of evolution that
it is hard to change the set point of
transcription that once you put in place
a transcriptional control system
changing it quantitatively is difficult
because of the cooperativity of it and
so if you're going to tune transcription
so you have less of a gene product more
of a gene product to do that you need
other mechanisms and actually I began to
think when phil was talking about the
secondary sites downstream from the
initiation of transcription which of
course fulfill that role you can control
those and get quantitative regulation of
the output of an already established
gene control system now it is the immune
system which which evolves fastest in
any multicellular organism because it
has to be tuned to the specific pathogen
load of that organism and as organisms
in evolution change their niches they
change their pathogen loads and require
that the immune system now quickly adapt
itself so that they can live in with it
with the new army of attackers that
they're going to face if this is all
true and if micro rna's are really
designed around rapidly evolving systems
then you might think that they would not
regulate core activities DNA synthesis
Krebs cycle
other things and I don't know if that's
true or not true because I didn't never
chance to actually think a lot about it
after after the thought came to my mind
so I put it on a slide but but I haven't
heard much about regulation of core
activities and so maybe this is a
thought worth following up all right
this is the hematopoietic series oh wait
here's the pneumatic stem cell it gives
rise to two kinds of progeny one through
the common lymphoid progenitor it gives
rise to T cells B cells and a number of
ancillary cells through the common
myeloid progenitor it gives rise to
erythrocytes to monitor monocytes and
macrophages neutrophils and and a
variety of other kinds of white blood
cells and of course make area sites that
in turn give rise to platelets it's a
beautiful system and some kind artists
around Caltech did a very nice job of
separating it out here and we made this
slide because we want to identify the
points at which microRNAs act and you
can you can't or can't see them but you
can see them a little black blur perhaps
at all of these various choice points
along the bifurcating systems of of
differentiation that make up the
hematopoietic series and I think it's
not unlikely that every pathway in
hematopoiesis will have micro rna's
involved but these are ones every one
that's on there are ones that where
there is now pretty good mutagenic
evidence knocked down evidence whatever
for their role in the differentiation of
these particular outputs and some of
them act early on in the in the
maturation series some of them act very
late in the maturation series but there
there are many there
so the way I view them today is as
collaborators with the transcription
factors and I've put a lot of
transcription factors that are also
known just in this little piece of the
tree the the formation of neutrophils
and macrophages to show the interactions
that are known with a variety of micro
rna's so against that background I want
to just talk about a relatively simple
system and that is micro RNAs that might
be induced by the NF kappa-b
transcription factor now we chose to
look at this because our laboratory has
been involved in trying to understand
this transcription factor for 25 years
now and what we knew very well from our
work and the work of many many other
people
was that an of Kappa B was central to
the inflammatory was in central to the
inflammatory response as well as to a
variety of other systems in the body and
that when you inactivate NF kappa-b in a
Cell it sits there as a latent ability
when you activate it that many genes are
turned on and so once micro RNA genes
came to my consciousness which isn't the
early part of the 2000s this seemed like
a reasonable question and Constantine
Tigana and Mark Bolden in particular
took a look at this question and what
they discovered was that when you induce
NF kappa-b for instance by treating
cells with lipid polysaccharide you get
3 micro rna's highly induced two of
these are themselves highly expressed
these are logged curves micro RNA 146
and 155 and we've focused our attention
on them 132 has other kinds of interests
and and I'm sure as yet an interest
story and the bottom line of everything
I'll say is that they have opposing
offense that 146 a and 155 do exactly
the opposite from each other
146 a is a repressor of inflammatory
responses so if we knock it out we get
hyper responsiveness and that leads
ultimately to cancers of a myeloid
system in particular 155 is on the other
hand a repressor of inhibitors of the
inflammatory reactions micro RNAs by
their nature are inhibitors and so the
way they activate things is by
inhibiting inhibitors and so it's an
activator and it's Lac it's knock out
leads to a hypo responsiveness of the
immune system and overproduction of 155
leads to a hyper proliferation in cancer
so these are directly opposing each
other
and in a sense it's not surprising that
you can get myeloid cells if you knock
out all micro rna's because if micro
rna's are set up more generally in these
opposing systems then it fits what again
what phil was saying about fine-tuning
the regulation of the system you have in
a sense two springs one going in each
direction and you can then set up make a
set point very effectively and I don't I
don't know how many other systems can be
described in this way so how does it
work mechanistically well there's no
actual relationship between what these
various proteins that these two proteins
do the way that near 1:46 works is this
lip a polysaccharide activates NF
kappa-b by activating through the tlr4
receptor that goes through a signal
transduction pathway involving iraq one
in traffic six and then after a bunch of
things happen and if Kappa B gets
activated and I've kept B goes and finds
genes
the binding sites and that one of those
jeans is 146
or 146 it's actually all all revolves
around 146 a which is one of two 146
jeans this in turn goes and inhibits the
trench the the translation or the
messenger RNA of Iraq one in trapped six
different amounts in different cells and
you had a story there but it's a
straightforward feedback inhibitor of
the trail of the strength of this
pathway so we didn't target a deletion
of it if you do that you knock out it's
very high expression and spleen you
knock out its activity and thymus and
bone marrow and the consequence and I'm
truncating lots of data most of this
being published already is that
inflammatory cytokines go up take il-6
is an example if you treat animals with
with lipid polysaccharide to induce an
inflammatory response you get a hyper
production of il-6 and it doesn't calm
down terribly well the consequence is
that if you look at if you treat animals
with a dose of LPS such that you don't
kill them but you do stress them then
the knockout cells die whereas wild-type
cells resist it fine and again it's
because of an over response to in this
case the analog of an infectious
challenge so does too to summarize a lot
of work you get an over response in
macrophages you can put them in culture
and show that they're hyper responsive
you get an extension of inflammatory
responses so a single activation leads
to a much longer response than it would
in a in a wild-type animal you see a
lack of resolution of t-cell responses
which is a consequence of a couple of
things one is poor tier egg function
because that the 146 knockout actually
makes poor Tigranes t-regulatory cells
and we did showed that in a paper with
sasha radensky who knows what he's
talking about
when it comes to tier eggs and there's a
slow activation induced cell death of
t-cells so when you activate t-cells up
they come they do their thing and then
they die because they're very powerful
cells you don't want them around if you
don't need them but in these animals
they're very slow to die and so you get
an extended response what happens over
time is that as the animals age you
build up pathology presumably as a
consequence of this continual
overreaction to inflammatory stimuli
ultimately leading to a chronic
inflammatory State this is pretty
obvious if you look at animals at about
six months of age they have huge spleens
they have huge lymph nodes
they are chronically producing an
inflammatory stimulus and these are
spleen weights it's very variable
some animals are spawned earlier in life
some later probably a reflection of
their particular encounters with
pathogens over time the animals die
early as a consequence of this even the
heads may have a small effect if you
look at these animals you see
infiltration of many organs in
particular liver kidney with with
myeloid cell infiltrates because these
animals are now in a state of continual
respond
you see flowing pro-inflammatory
cytokines often a very high constitutive
levels and you start getting Auto
antibody production because the
consequence of this kind of
of continual activation is autoimmune
disease get a breakdown of peripheral
t-cell tolerance and so what happens is
in an animal that's a few months old the
t-cells all look activated those are in
the in the slime the hatches the the
wild-type control or the filled things
are wild-type control and you can see
that there's an up regulation these are
animals that we haven't manipulated at
all just left in the animal aisles of CD
69 is a down regulation of homing
receptors at 62 L there's an
upregulation of cd44 so this is a
serious problem you wait a year with
these animals now they have huge spleens
and you start seeing Frank tumors and
these are Frank tumor cells in enlarged
masses to be found in these animals we
did this on the background of C 57 times
129 mice because that's what we used for
the original knockouts I mentioned that
because it'll come up with a second and
that is that at this point
Jimmy Zhou who was an empty PhD student
joined my lab and we had a cohort of
these animals that we had made on a
different background a pure C 57
background and we now in fact use those
for everything because they're just a
constant background and what he found
was that these animals developed two
kinds of tumors again it just about the
year to eighteen months of age one kind
are called myeloid sarcoma
there is sort of solid tumor of myeloid
cells and the other 20% are lymphomas
you can see one here this is a b-cell
lymphoma at cd19
almost all the cells or cd19 positive
and you get mixed being t-cell lymphomas
with some that are cd3 positive and some
that are cd19 positive but the bulk of
the two of these are these myeloid
sarcoma that have C D 11 B on their
surface so what's the relationship with
where we started to where we are now
that is to NF kappa-b
well Jimmy looked at the animals of the
knockout animals and compared them to
wild-type animals from the point of view
of gene expression and spleen cells in
animals that show myeloid proliferation
but not tumors and what he found was
that all of the marker genes that he
used were up in their transcription
aisle six TNF alpha a twentieth century
this is true in spleen cells it's true
in bone marrow it's true and purified
myeloid cells and if you look at the
nuclei of such cells you see an
increased amount of P 65 the one of the
subunits of NF kappa-b so this clearly
up regulation of NF kappa-b both of the
level of the protein going to the
nucleus and of the genes that are being
regulated so he said in that case can we
show that NF kappa-b
is centrally involved in the tumorigenic
process so he we trust these 146
knockout animals with animals that lack
the p50 subunit of NF kappa-b
for a variety of reasons that's the
easiest thing to do and that then
reduced spleen weights it you can see
that probably best here it reduced bone
marrow the bone marrow excess of myeloid
cells and
the red blood cells which are now being
made in these animals in the spleen
because their bone marrow is so full of
violated filtration that also clears up
if you cross them with a p53
these animals have not gotten tumors
they have some there they have some
problems still we haven't regular eyes
everything about them but I think we can
say pretty clearly that it is the the
continual activation of NF kappa-b over
the parent over this year of time which
is causing the problem and really brings
home the importance of controlling
inflammation as was said by some earlier
speaker I think Harold Varmus actually
in in disease so from the functional
feedback studies for the functional
studies
it appears that 146 a is a feedback
regulator of inflammatory activation
helping to shut down NF kappa-b and if
you lack 146 you get a high sensitivity
to LPS poor resolution of t-cell
activation
many hallmarks of of chronic
inflammation and ultimately cancer you
see that in the knockouts at six months
by infiltration of myeloid cells and by
a year with Frank tumors of various
sorts the the fact that all of this
seems to need the p50 subunit of NF
kappa-b
suggests that it's actually not a
problem so much of NF kappa-b
in the tumor cells as probably the the
inflammatory environment in which these
cells have lived so that's one side of
the story the other side is as I said
I'll talk about Mir 155 it's over
expression causes a myeloproliferative
disease
and just just countered to what 1:46
does this work was largely done by Ryan
O'Connell and Dinesh Rao to postdoctoral
fellows who are now moving into
independent positions the experiment
that I that got me thinking about all of
this was a relatively simple experiment
you just inject Lippo polysaccharide
into a wild-type Mouse take out bone
marrow at various times thereafter and
we looked at two things we looked at Mir
155 activation and sure enough near 155
is activated very highly in bone marrow
cells that's mixed bone marrow cells if
you try to separate them you find it
particularly high in progenitor cell and
that calms down over time and if you
look at the cells that are being made by
the bone marrow
if you injected PBS or you just had
wild-type animals you get about a third
b-cells a third myeloid cells and the
other third is largely in this case
they're on unlabeled but they're largely
erythroid precursors those are the big
output from the bone marrow red blood
cells B cells and mylord's animals that
we treat with a polysaccharide for a
couple of days or they were treated with
a la vallee saccharide once and we
waited a couple of days are now making
largely mylord's and that's interesting
it's interesting because most people I
didn't know it was in the literature if
you look for it that the bone marrow
output was so malleable and secondly
that it would focus so much on on
myeloid cells but it makes sense because
the major stress that an animal that's
highly infected in an animal treated
with lipopolysaccharide thinks it's
highly in fact the major stress is in
the myeloid compartment that's trying to
kill off bacteria that that are carrying
the LPS
so we did a gain-of-function experiment
with 1:55 to see if there was a linkage
between this increased 155 and the
increased myeloid celebrant and we did
that by making a retro viral vector that
expresses 1:55 we can show in raw cells
that it's expressed very nicely and it
gives rise both to green cells because
we have GFP and two cells that have high
levels of 155 constitutively we then put
this into the bone marrow of mice
lethally irradiated recipient mice put
in the the modified bone marrow waited a
few months and now the amount of poetic
system has been reconstituted with cells
some 50 to 80 percent of which are over
expressing 1:55 and what are the
consequences of that consequences are
very clear the bone marrow is no longer
red it's it's yellow because we're
making very few red blood cells you can
look by at by histology and see that the
marrow is a sheet of myeloid cells the
ordinary obvious platelet precursors and
and lymphocytes and others are all gone
some of these are are aberrant many of
them seem pretty normal and you can see
them by by other kinds of analyses so
what was going on
first thing is we can say that that 155
probably is a major determinant of what
kinds of cells come out of the bone
marrow and that in an inflammatory
situation it can really change the bone
marrow into a into a myeloid producing
organ but what's its target
and 1:55 has a long history and I'm not
gonna give you that whole history but
most of it involves the importance of
1:55 in in lymphoid cells and in cancer
and people had been searching for years
but what was the key target of 1:55 so
we started looking through data that we
got in the lab when we when we made
tests of its specificity as well as
bioinformatics and ultimately came down
to ship one as a candidate and it was
largely because it made sense you could
have made arguments for all sorts of
other targets because because there are
probably a hundred good targets but none
of them made the clear sense that ship
won so ship what is inositol five prime
phosphate ace it's expressed in him at a
poetic compartment known to function as
a tumor suppressor known to inhibit the
pi3 kinase signaling pathway as a
phosphatase it it is a it counters the
biochemistry of pi3k it's known to
regulate cytokines and if you sort of
put it all together it looks like it
could be exactly the opposite of 155 and
so since 155 has to be a negative
regulator of whatever it's regulating
you would expect that the functions of
ship 1 would be exactly the counter to
155 if that's what it controlled and you
can see that the site is really a very
beautiful site for the seed region of
155 so we overexpressed ship one sorry
we over expressed a si RNAi against ship
one and if feed-up copied 155 you get
this huge amount of myeloid cells now
Express slightly differently than we did
before with c xi b on the y axis and gfp
on the x
and you could also see it in the
pictures that ship one marrow and ship
one knockdown marrow and 155 marrow
looks similar and so I think we can say
with some degree of certainty the chip
ship one is a key target probably not
the only target there's other reason to
believe that socks one is a target in
particular in T regulatory cells and
that there are a couple of others in
other cells and actually that's a theme
that we see running through things is
that you could often find one target in
one kind of cell but another target in
another kind of cell so a summary of
what we know about 155 is that like 146
a its induced by inflammatory simulate
stimuli but unlike it the target
specificity doesn't suggest anything
like a negative feedback but rather a
positive role in inflammation that the
key target appears to be ship one and it
has been knocked out it's been knocked
out in two laboratories and it has
multiple effects they were they were
interested in T cells and B cells and it
has multiple effects in T cells and B
cells but we've now looked at it in by
light cell in the myeloid cell context
I'll show you that in one moment an
uncontrolled experiment expression of
155 leads to myeloid proliferation
because it controls myeloid related
genes we don't see Frank cancers but the
animals don't really live long enough to
see that they die of secondary problems
that arise from not having a marrow
that's functional so a positive link
between NF kappa-b expression and cancer
in this case may be the continual 155
production and many human cancers show
overproduction
1:55 but let me go back to the knockout
and the the prediction you'd make of a
knockout of 1:55 is that it would be
immunosuppressed because if it's a
positive activator of of the immune
system and then if you knock it out you
should not get as much immune function
we chose to look at that using e AE
experimental autoimmune encephalitis as
a model because that is a reflection of
the strength of the immune response in
an animal even though it's an autoimmune
response rather than a response to a
foreign organism and you can see what
I'm going to show you it with other
kinds of tests but this one is
particularly strong so the way you get
an e AE response is you inject the
peptide from a mile in protein into the
animals they make a response to the
peptide they start demyelinating their
own nerves and you can read it out as a
as a behavioral problem they start being
unable to use their tail their back legs
they get very ill they most of them
actually recover from and sure enough in
the mere 155 knockout you get a much
weaker EI e response in fact some 40% of
the animals get no detectable response
and the other ones have a weak response
as scored by a standardized scored that
I won't bother you with
so 155 knockouts ei e is mutated this is
largely due as we can show by cell
transfer experiments and others had
shown for ei e in other circumstances
due to cd4 cells in particular the
defect looks like it's a defect in the
functioning of a subset of cd4 cells
called th17 cells cells that make a lot
of of il-17 there's also some defect in
the induction of il-17 producing cells
we originally thought that that might be
the primary effect but it seems to be
more in the function of the cells but
this is a reflection of the fact that
that drit excel function is is down in
these knockout animals and so they make
fewer th17 cells that depend on
dendritic cell signaling so mere 155 is
a necessary part of setting the positive
side of the immune system it acts by
relieving an inhibitory effect of ship 1
and as i said probably stocks going to
and a fine it is part of the fine tuning
mechanism of the strength of the immune
response but if you don't keep it under
control you over produce it then you get
problems of hyper proliferative disorder
and cancer in humans just I'm not going
to tell you this story of another micro
RNA we've gotten interested in 125 B I
just want to show one thing which is
when you overexpress 125 B basically the
same kind of experiment that I showed
you for 155 you get the most massive
overproduction of myeloid cells we've
seen this is what marrow begins to look
like here and you can see in filtration
the liver and elsewhere it's by 6 months
of age or by here here by four and a
half months
you have a leukemia and just huge liver
and spleen nodules of tumor cells these
are transplantable into
immunocompromised animals they are one
of the most remarkable tumors I've I've
seen and this is sort of my poster child
for a lot of micro RNA to do it let
loose so I think we're still scratching
the surface of understanding the roles
of micro rna's and just even if you just
focus on the immune and inflammatory
cell development on the functions of
these cells 125 be actually as
remarkable effects on the function of my
love of macrophages makes them more more
active and on cellular proliferation we
know some targets in some kinds of cells
we know some of the regulators of the
synthesis of these things we know how
easy it is to elicit remarkable for a
lipid of dysregulation by either
knockouts or over productions but we
don't really yet understand the setting
of that set point that I think these
have their major role in physical major
role in physiology and with that I thank